leave my first question is for you
because I am mildly obsessed with the
motion camera so I'm just wondering are
you brainstorming any other new camera
techniques to kind of spice that up for
your next future yes I'm trying to think
of a movie I'm trying to think of a plot
to to marry to these techniques you know
like shooting movies with Stefan do Co
the cinematographer in in unique ways in
any way you can you know sometimes you
don't have the budget to be too unique
but you can try things you know you you
can always get creative even if you
don't have a lot of money at your
disposal so yeah I really would love to
kind of push that you know I always
loved film makers that have a signature
style you know you look at Scorsese or
you know Tim Burton Sam Raimi there's
certain filmmakers who this style is
very unique to them and and and so I'd
like I like having a style that maybe
people associate with me like the crew
on this film the stunt crew if we were
ever doing a motion-control shot they
would call it over now they'd be like
alright let's do a Whannell and and I
was loving that cuz I was like cool so
I've got this thing that's my trademark
I'm gonna start repeating that and just
make that thing speaking of trademarks
Jason you are definitely known for
maximizing small budgets and now also
having pretty great success with
bringing back familiar properties in new
ways so just with Invisible Man in
particular are there any lessons you've
learned for rebooting properties that
you know it's kind of like adding
another tool to that toolbox that you
could take to future ones not as much as
confirming you know the tenant of the
company the beliefs I already have which
is that when you're doing shun remove
ease not action movies you know not not
Marvel movies but when you're doing shun
remove ease they really benefit from
character drama
and being intimate and small and money
and effects and stunts do not make genre
movies better in fact I would argue they
make them worse and if anything Lee's
movie really confirmed that for me again
easy for me to say because I didn't have
to work on the shoestring of a budget
that he did and he may not want to admit
it but I think that it does it does push
a better creative when you can't rely on
toys on the set I I do agree when it
comes to horror if you look at the
history of horror as a genre and if I if
I said to you okay quick name 20 iconic
horror movies the chances are a large
percentage of the horror movies that you
would name would be independent movies
you know Flair Witch Project Halloween
Paranormal Activity you know what I mean
so it takes us Chainsaw Massacre like in
what other genre can you say that all of
those stars of the genre the benchmarks
are independently made movies it's
pretty rare and I think Jason's right
I'd begrudgingly admit as the guy trying
to figure out how to shoot these movies
on a low budget I'd begrudgingly admit
that horror just works better when it's
smaller I think if you're trying to make
a sci-fi movie if you're trying to make
a Star Wars yeah you need that big
canvas I think the only example that I
can think of otherwise is one you'd
probably like and it's the conjuring
like a big-budget
drizzy a bigger budget at least maybe
not the size of a Marvel movie but
bigger than you know the bone marrow of
that movie on paper it's it's all set in
one house one house could have
completely made that film on this guy I
think I think that's actually a failure
I think it's an interesting point I
think it's somewhat a fair point the
first conjuring movie though was a
relatively low budget it was I think 16
or 18 and and again a lot of that goes
to above the line and we pay people and
back end not not not up front but the
DNA of the conjuring movies is very just
like Lee said it's not you know it's not
it's not spectacle
by any means well that whole first movie
is totally character-driven that is what
makes it make its mark the tube yes yeah
exactly yeah yeah so I am mighty excited
to finally be able to talk Invisible Man
spoilers with you and the first thing I
was wondering because I've grown a
little obsessed with watching it over
and over and trying to figure out who's
wearing the suit at which time me do you
know Adrian or Tom who is wearing it at
every single moment the film well yeah I
Tom's only wearing it once without
spoiling it for and I think you as a
viewer you know that what that moment is
the rest of the time it's Adrian okay
all right that confirms a lot of well
I'm gonna brand this with a big spoiler
warning nothing cool I was also at the
earlier junket this year dying to ask
you about the suit in particular are
there any kind of real-life you know
tech examples of what inspired the
design of that suit not really I think
that there are real-life examples of
invisibility camouflage that the
military is working on and you don't
have to go on too much of a of an
internet deep dive to find articles
about this but the design of the suit I
sort of wanted it to be cinematic you
know so I wanted it to be scary and
iconic so I'm trying to make it
something that could feel real but also
iconic you know because
horror really thrives on those iconic
images you know if you think about
pinhead or Michael Myers there's an
instant visual there and so I wanted
that instant visual and I liked that
look at the suit that weird black you
know Blade Runner bondage suit whatever
the hell it was
I really liked where we got to with that
you know it was like a I don't know if
it's iconic but I think it was striking
I feel like the image of the pain
being thrown could soon become iconic
there's something about that that
whether someone's seen the full movie or
not I feel like that image is pretty
universal at this point yeah maybe
there's a mean there a lot of people
were saying when before it came out that
they were like wait the Invisible Man is
a golf ball because when she threw the
paint yeah so but but yeah I mean I
would be so happy if in ten years from
now people still talked about this movie
and and and there was some iconic images
from I'm not just saying it because
we're talking right now but I really
believe it it's up there is one of my
favorites of 2020 right now the other
bid I wanted to ask you about was the
ending conversation between James and
Cecilia I'm just curious was is the
iteration that we see in the final film
always how you were ending it or is that
something that needed massaging along
the way during the screenwriting stage
there was a bit of a change there I
think working with Blum House they
really helped with feedback on what
would be the best ending for the film
and we talked about it and then once we
got to the set I think Elizabeth moss
and Ann Aldous Hodge we played James
they really had something to contribute
and so everybody that's what's great
about movies movies is is that everybody
throws in their opinions and you get
it's like a collection of good opinions
if you're lucky you know that's why I
don't take a film by credit you know I'm
not trying to be falsely modest I just
feel like there's too many other people
contributing to the movie to to pretend
that I was like the one guy doing it all
so yeah I appreciate that Jason one
thing I'm dying to ask you about is I
was reading a little bit about the
possible Blum House production that
might shoot on the universal lot soon
and you know I'm a great admirer of your
company in the way that your productions
work so the idea of you potentially
setting the blueprint for future
production shooting given the
circumstances right now is is very
encouraging to me so what is
some tool or some way of working that
you think is gonna change the game in
that respect that you're gonna put into
practice on that movie we're not going
to put into practice anything different
than what the the governor is is
suggesting and that and I think the the
thing that I'm most focused on is making
sure that that obviously we're doing
we're putting a plan together with all
the Guild's and I want to make sure the
guilds are comfortable and feel good
about the plan as opposed to coming up
with the plan and just saying hey this
is what we're doing can we get your your
rubber stamp of approval because they
obviously have have they want to get
their members back to work but they
obviously have a ton of concerns and so
I think I think what we're doing most
differently on this movie is taking the
guidelines from the government and then
concocting a plan with our you know
friends at all the guilds so that we do
something that that not just we or
Universal but that all of you know all
of the people that we work with and
their representatives feel feel positive
about that and get a consensus and and
it's been going well it's an enormous of
an enormous amount of work but it's been
moving slowly but surely forward and
knock on wood now not for sure but uh
but I think we'll be able to shoot
something in in about six weeks I'm
rooting for you guys i I know that
people sometimes roll their eyes of you
know people obsessing over movies and TV
right now but I know I for one need
content like that in order to be able to
process the real stuff that I'm living
through so thank you for being in the
new films and new content I'll take
whatever I can get right now guys thank
you so much for your time and yet
another congratulations on this one
Thanks thank you thanks very much nice
to see you